the one thing that wasn't expected
happened US airlines are closely
following the investigation into the
crash of a passenger jet off Indonesia
today the plane was a new Boeing 737 max
out of millions of things they tested
for we unfortunately found one that
wasn't breaking news out of Ethiopia
where a plane went down just outside the
capital killing everyone on board the
Boeing 737 max 8 is the same model
involved in the Indonesian lion air jet
crash in October no aircraft
manufacturer gets a free disaster or two
disasters when these crashes are
preventable by long-established
aerodynamic engineering standards the
crisis surrounding the crashes of the
Boeing 737 max eight planes in Ethiopia
and Indonesia has seized the world's
attention and done something perhaps
even more remarkable unite Congress do
you think the FAA has the responsibility
to tell these airlines that they cannot
shut change safety for profits as a
passenger
I would certainly find it troubling if
the captain is describing the training
manual as quote inadequate and almost
criminally insufficient this is a recent
congressional hearing during which
senators from both parties grilled this
man dan Elwell the Acting Federal
Aviation Administration chief about the
recent Boeing crashes safety is at the
core of the FAS mission it is our first
priority I will testify about a wide
range of issues but the most serious
questions concerned the FAA relationship
with the industry it regulates I suppose
that there's always a question of why we
would have a private company certify
their product and that's something many
Americans might not know or appreciate
the federal agency in charge of making
sure new planes are safe doesn't
actually do those inspections anymore
instead it outsources certifications to
the plane manufacturers themselves the
US government is is not arm's length
with these manufacturers there's too
much delegation of public responsibility
for airline travel safety you might
recognize this man
Ralph Nader is a former Green Party
presidential candidate and prominent
consumer advocate Nader is why we have
seatbelts and airbags and cars
he's also been sounding the alarm about
what he sees as the cozy relationship
between the FAA and aircraft
manufacturers like Boeing for years he
even wrote a book about it in 1994 it's
a captive agency it's captive by the
airline industry and the aircraft
manufacturers who swarm over it who get
their executives appointed as officials
of the FAA so this book is designed to
encourage an attitude of prevention of
foreseen for stalling why wait for the
crashes to occur
recently the issue became more personal
for Nader his grandniece Sammy Rose Stu
Moe was killed in the 737 max crash in
Ethiopia
she was only 24 but in her short life
she had an advanced degree in global
health we'll never know how many lives
she would have saved in a 50-year career
we can trace the roots of the modern FAA
back to a major change the agency
instituted in 2005 back then the Bush
administration loosened regulations to
allow manufacturers to use their own
employees to certify the safety of their
planes this was part of a cost-cutting
initiative dubbed Oda or the
organization designation authorization
program this cushy relationship between
the FAA and Boeing has got to end
and it congress has got to stand up
provide adequate budgets and adequate
technical staff to do their job in a
statement the FAA said the agency has
never allowed companies to police
themselves or self-certify their
aircraft before the ODA came into effect
the FAA would choose its own inspectors
some of those inspectors may have worked
for the manufacturer but they were
chosen and supervised by the FAA today
under the ODA system Boeing employees
certify the safety of Boeing's own
planes grenadier and the agency's
critics this is a clear conflict of
interest but for the FAA is defenders
these concerns are overblown the
certification process the FAA is
involved from start to finish if you
went out to Boeing or Airbus or anywhere
where aircraft certification was
underway you would find FAA pilots
engineers all part of the process
working shoulder-to-shoulder I don't
think you could operate the airline
industry or the commercial aircraft
industry without it and that's something
both sides can agree on today the FAA
simply cannot do all of these
inspections because it doesn't have the
manpower or the resources if we had no
Oda and it would require roughly 10,000
more employees in about a 1.8 billion
dollars for our certification office in
the FAA
this would be a major increase from the
FAS 2019 budget of 239 million dollars
and 1,300 staff we would also represent
a significant change to the agency's
marching orders considering that for the
past 15 years Congress has asked the FAA
to tighten its belt and deregulate every
decade or so this catches the attention
of folks who are
in the aviation business Congress the
press you're cranky uncle they scratch
their heads what do you mean the
government is working with the airlines
aren't they supposed to be regulating
those guys this is a speech that Elwell
gave last year to an industry lobbying
group I get it
I get that thinking that thought process
but the relationship that exists between
the FAA
ALPA and the rest of the industry that
we regulate is the driving force behind
our unprecedented safety record and that
is perhaps the FAA is best defense
despite these recent crashes modern air
safety for large transport aircraft in
America is better than ever since 1997
the risk of a fatal commercial aviation
accident in the United States has been
cut by 94% and in the past 10 years
we've experienced one commercial airline
paced passenger fatality in the United
States in over 90 million flights that's
a remarkable record so then what
happened with these two flights since
both investigations are still ongoing
it's too early to say but former FAA
head Babbitt thinks the answer is an
uncomfortable one I'm not trying to be
defensive of the FAA but I would imagine
there's probably more than a hundred
thousand tests were done on this
aircraft and to have a shortcoming in
one that's one shortcoming too many but
out of the mass of literally and
millions of permutations of what could
happen you know what the goal line--
every now and then the holes and the
Swiss cheese line up and that's what
happened
but the agency's critics see things very
differently for them the two recent
crashes are further proof that
deregulation has gotten out of control
and that industry has effectively taken
over the FAA for Nader
a case in point is the men at the top
dan Elwell
well that was part of the industry FAA
turnstile they go in they go out the
current acting FAA had has spent his
career bouncing between government and
industry fortunately he's on his way out
is gonna be a new FAA commissioner the
problem is he's from Delta so here we go
again Boeing is determined to salvage
the 737 max 8 which is the fastest
selling plane in the company's history
to that end they are working on a
software fix that they hope will get the
max aids back in the air flying again
this summer but the growing public
scrutiny of the manufacturer could
undermine that deadline and perhaps even
Boeing's influence within the FAA a
recent Wall Street Journal investigation
found that Boeing didn't share
information about a problem with a
cockpit safety alert system for about a
year before the first max crash in
Indonesia that left not only the flying
public in the dark but also the FAA it
was only after the second accident in
Ethiopia nearly five months later that
Boeing became more forthcoming about the
problem
Boeing said it operates in full
accordance with all Federal Aviation
Administration oversight requirements
and processes the long-standing
collaborative engagement between the FAA
Boeing its customers and industry
partners has created the safest
transportation system in the world
[Music]